Jamal Kershaw gee I can't say it you
can't spill it and a week ago most of us
had never heard of him but in case you
missed it he is suddenly become the
biggest story in the world
exiled Saudi journalist Jamal khashoggi
walked into the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul and didn't come out at least
not in one piece we think there are
allegations of murder dismemberment by
Saudi hit squads bone saws and a
gruesome audio recording of it all going
down many are asking the question how
could this possibly happen to a
high-profile exile who's been writing
critical stories about the Saudi regime
for The Washington Post ever since Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman tried to
silence him your guess is as good as
mine although Trump thinks it could be
some rogue killers
lucky me the US has said that the Saudis
will carry out a full investigation into
what happened in their own consulate
that should put minds at ease others are
wondering why Turkey's President Erdogan
who's not particularly known for his
love of critical journalists retaining
their life and Liberty happens to be so
upset about this particular journalist
who happens to be one of his closest
friends we just don't know what we do
know is that this situation is proving a
little awkward for some people it risks
uncovering one of the biggest secrets in
geopolitics and that is that everyone is
a hypocrite for the West this is
all one big pain in the backside
there's a dead journalist which they
hate but a big fat bucket load of Saudi
cash which they love it's a choice
between the basic human right to keep
breathing and government's desire to
keep selling murderous weapons to
despots that's a no brainer we can
expect the US and Europe to impose
wide-ranging sanctions on Saudi Arabia
any day now then there's the dip
so Saudi leader Mohammed bin Salman or
MBS which is the BS nickname he's picked
up his attempt at rebranding himself as
a cuddly reformer appears to be severely
hampered by all the killing he's been
ordering allegedly you know who's really
angry though Yemen one Khashoggi gets
more headlines than thousands of Yemeni
civilians killed by the Saudi regime
make friends with the president right
for The Washington Post
then people will care